[音楽]
彼の名前はアレックスと言います
彼の国は東ティモールと言って
岩手県ほどの小さな国ですマンゴーや
パパイヤが最高に美味しくてエメラルド
グリーンの海に囲まれたとても美しい島
です
私は縁あってこの国の言葉を学び手探りで
映画を作りました
映画作りに至る私の旅の始まりは10歳の
頃でした家の周りの雑木林が
宅地開発で一面ブルドーザーで更地になっ
ていたの目の当たりにしたんです
森に住む生き物や木々に一言の挨拶もなく
なぎ倒していく大人たちの姿にただただ
驚きショックを受けました18歳になって
ある絵本からアメリカ大陸先住民の存在を
知り
衝撃を受けました
生き物たちを敬い
森を殺そうとしない大人たちがこの世界に
はいるどうしても会いたくなってカナダへ
行きましたそこから足やポリネシアと
古い知恵を伝える先住民族の方々に会って
いきましたそんな中でたどり着いたのが
東ティモールでした
初めて会った時アレックスは子供たちに
囲まれて歌を歌っていましたその歌の内容
はこんな風でした僕らは過ちを犯す大地は
知っている私にはその僕らの過ちが何を
指しているのかわかりませんでした彼が
生まれた国東ティモールは
1975年ポルトガルの植民地から
独立を宣言します
しかしその直後お隣のインドネシアが軍事
侵攻を開始しました
東ティモールは65万人ほどが住む小さな
国です
1日あれば
陥落すると言われていました
それほど
圧倒的な武力がこの国を襲ったのです
東ティモールはたちまち地獄と化しました
3人に1人に当たる20万人以上が
命を落としたのです
国連は黙っていませんでした
正式な決議を8回も出して
軍の撤退を求めたのです
でもその決議に反対してまでインドネシア
の軍事侵攻を支援する国々がありました
それが日本やアメリカオーストラリアと
いったいわゆる大国でした
中でも日本はその国連決議8回全てに
反対票を投じるいわゆる先進国の中では
唯一の国でした
なぜそんなことが起きたのでしょうか一つ
の大きな理由は
ティモールを気に沈む
巨大な油田でした地下資源の確保や市場の
拡大といったメリットのためには
非道な行為も
黙認され続けたのです
爆撃の中アレックスのお母さんは子供を
抱えてジャングルへ逃げ込みました
アレックスはたくさんの家族を失いながら
生き延びましたそして9歳の頃彼は目の前
で大好きなお父さんを失うことになります
彼のお父さんは
膀胱の末飛行機で引きずられて命を落とす
という
凄惨な最期を遂げました
彼はそれを目の当たりにしとても大きな
トラウマを抱えることになりますがその
出来事が同時に彼を力強い平和運動家にし
ました
10代になりアレックスは平和を求める
デモなどを起こすようになりましたそんな
ことをするとすぐ軍に連行されますそして
何回も彼は
拷問を受けることになるんです
東モールの人々は
山に潜みあるいは
命がけで国外へ脱出して
軍の行いが間違っていること私たちは平和
を求めているということを
訴えて回りました
聞いてくれる相手がたった一人でも
丁寧に伝え続けましたその地道な活動が
24年間続いたんです
そして1999年ついに群馬撤退しました
民家の9割が破壊されインフラの7割が
破壊されたその廃墟の中から東ティモール
の国づくりが始まりまし
た初めてこの国へ行こうと思ったのは大学
生の時でした
東ティモールの独立式典に参加しようと
思ったんです
でも飛行機からこの島が見えた時私の膝は
震え始めました
常に
軍事攻撃の世界最大のスポンサーだったの
は日本ですその日本からどんな顔して会い
に行けばいいんだろう
石を投げられるかもしれない
怖い引き返したいでも飛行機はついて
しまいます私は恐る恐る降り立ち止めて
いただく家に行きましたそこの家の
お母さんが出てきてくれて彼女の顔を見た
瞬間
私は涙が止まらなくなりました
どうしたのどっか痛いのって心配されて私
はごめんなさい私何も知らずに日本から来
ちゃいましたごめんなさいって言ったら
彼女はあのね国家と人間は違うの
インドネシアの人も日本の人も
命がけで私たちの島に
助けに来てくれた私たちはそれを決して
忘れない国と人を混同していたら私たちの
島に平和は来なかったという話をしてくれ
たんです
私は彼女の言葉に勇気をもらって
島を回る決意をしました3人に1人が命を
失うということはどこの家を訪ねても誰か
が亡くなっています
行く先々であまりにも悲しい出来事を
見聞きし私は言葉を失いました
街を歩けば
焼け焦げた建物が連なっていました
浜辺にはビニールシートが敷かれて
たくさんの人々が寝泊まりしていました
きっと
傷を受けて泣いてる人たちがいるんだろう
怒ってるかもしれない
恐る恐る近づいていくとなんとハーモニカ
の音が聞こえたんです
中を覗いてみるとどこから来たという
大きな声がして
ほんの少しの練乳にたっぷりのお湯を混ぜ
た特製ドリンクでもてなしていただきまし
た
過酷な状況の中にあっても私の想像を
はるかに超えて人の命はたくましくそこに
は音楽があり笑いがありました
私はアレックスを探し出し
なぜ僕らの過ちと歌うのかその理由を聞き
ましたインドネシアや日本の過ち彼らの
過ちではなくなぜ僕らなのかでも彼は
そんなことより島を見せてあげると言って
私たちの旅が始まりました
島を回って私が一番驚いたのは大人たちの
瞳の穏やかさでし
たつい最近拷問にあったような人たち目の
前で家族を失った人たちが日本から来た
人間をまっすぐ見て
今日どこ泊まるんだうち止まっていき
なさいお腹空いてないかともてなして
くれるんです
その瞳には
怯えや疑いがなくてその光はまっすぐ私の
胸を突き刺しましたこの穏やかさの秘密は
何だろう私はその秘密に触れたくて映画
作りを決心し
島の奥深くへ入っていきました
撮影は約400時間に及びました
軍を撤退させるまでこの島の人たちが取っ
た戦略は私には驚くべきものでし
た彼らは
敵方であるインドネシア兵を捉えると
殺すのではなくて自分たちのキャンプに
連れ帰るん
ですそして自分たちが平和を望んでいる
こと戦いを望んでいないことを伝えて対話
をし無傷のまま
元の軍にそっと返すんですね
インドネシア兵の中には
ティモールの人たちと対話をするうちに
軍に身を置きながら
東ティモールの独立を助ける人たちも出て
きましたこれはとても危険な行為です
でもこんな風にして東ティモールは仲間を
増やしていきついに平和を勝ち取ったの
です
でも相手は自分の家族を殺したような相手
自分の娘をレイプしたような相手です
そんな相手と対話ができるでしょうか
首都を少し離れ山に入れば電気が注いの来
ていない村がほとんどでした山での暮らし
の中には
瞑想のような時間がいっぱいあります誰も
瞑想なんて言わないんですけど
ぼーっとする時間がいっぱいあるんです朝
行ってきますって家を出た時にあぜ道に
座っていたおじさんと牛が
夕方帰ってきても同じ場所に同じ格好で
座っていたりする
私も試しにやってみましたでもすぐ
そわそわしちゃってなかなかうまくいか
ないんですでもある時自分の体が
畦道に溶け込んだような瞬間がありました
体の境目がほどけて無限に広がっていく
ような感覚です
この国では子供から大人まで毎日こんな
時間がふんだんにあるのかと
驚きました
汗に溶け込んだ体から世界を見てみると
あなたと私の境界も曖昧になっていきます
実際彼らの共通語ペトゥン語にはそれが
現れていましたペトゥン語ではあなたの
こといたと言いますこの板という単語が
同時に私たちって意味になるんですあなた
の家は私たちの家あなたの子供は私たちの
子供これ誰のって聞くとイタリアンという
答えが返ってきます2アンは所有を表すの
であなたのだよって帰ってくるいや私の
じゃないんだよ誰のって聞いても
イタリアン
私たちのだからみんなのだから使って
いいよっていう答えなんです最初は混乱し
ましたが彼らと生活を共にするうちあなた
と私を分けることがそもそも
あまり意味がないことのように思えていき
ました
アレックスが彼らの過ちではなく僕たちの
過ちと歌っていた理由はこういった文化に
土台がありました
あなたと私が曖昧な世界では私はあなたに
感謝しますという言葉もありません日本
から支援物資を持っていくと向こうの
お父さんはそれを受け取ってうんと力強く
頷いてくれます
家族だから助け合うのは当然こっちは
任せろそっちは任せたっていう頷きなん
ですそういった場面で感謝を表す外来語の
オブリガード」って言われると
お客さん扱いされてるって
寂しくなるんです
思えばこういう言葉の世界は私が旅をした
アメリカ大陸やアジアやポリネシアにも
共通していました日本語でも手前やわれ
己と言った自分を指しているのか相手を
指しているのか
曖昧な言葉があります
私たちの意識がこんなにも物事を分断する
ようになったのはつい最近のことなのかも
しれません
一度境目を曖昧にして周りを見てみて
ください誰かが賞を取ったそれはもう一人
の自分でもある
嬉しい誰かを愛したと同時にあなたは愛さ
れている
比較をして焦る必要もなく良い発想は
どんどんシェアしてみんなで良くなって
いける
自国のために他国に侵略に行くなんて発想
もなくなっていく
東ティモールにはこうした相手も自分の
一部だとする
文化の土台があったからこそ
敵方の兵士との対話も成り立ったんだと
思います
それがなくては戦争は泥沼と化した
でしょうこれはすごいことだと思います
私たちは東ティモールの旅を映画にまとめ
て2011年から上映を始めました
アレックスとも交流が続きましたが
今から5年前彼は
亡くなりました
心臓発作による
突然の訃報でした
電気ショックを含む
拷問の後遺症で
突然死をする人は
ティモールにはたくさんいます彼もそうか
もしれません
でも彼は最後の瞬間まで子供たちに語って
いました
いいか人間は大丈夫だ俺たちは小さいでも
その小さな一人の中にとてつもない力が
あるんだ
戦争始めたのは誰だ人間だ
終わらせるのは誰だ人間なんだ俺たちなん
だ
いいか人間には力がある大丈夫
だたとえ拷問に遭い家族を目の前で失い
自分も早く死ぬことになっても彼はきっと
最後の瞬間まで人間を信じていました
今この世界を皆さんはどう見ている
でしょう
戦争も自然破壊も誰にも止められないかの
ように進んでいますひどいニュースが
飛び交う世界
です人間なんて信頼できない大人になんて
なりたくないという子どもたちもたくさん
いるかもしれない
でも東ティモールの人たちは人間は信頼
できる
信頼に足る存在なんだと言っています
どれだけひどい目にあったり何度裏切られ
て
家族や自分の体の一部を失ってもそれでも
目の前の人間を信じるということどうし
たって花が咲こうとするように
傷が治っていこうとするように人間もどう
したって良くなろうとしている
何世代かかってでも私たちはよくなって
いくんだと
着物の人々に会って私も信じられるように
なりました
アレックスは生前帰国しようとする私に
伝言を託してくれましたこんな伝言です
あなたの仲間が10人にしか見えなくて
対するものが大きくて
巨大で1000人にも見えても
あなたのやろうとしていること
それが
命に沿ったこと
命が喜ぶ仕事であれば
そこにはなくなった人たちもこれから
生まれてくる人たちもついていてくれる
それは先どころじゃないから絶対に大丈夫
だから
恐れないで続けてください
仕事の途中で
命を落とすことがあるかもしれない
それでも大丈夫だから
恐れないで心細くなった時は僕たちのこと
を思い出してほしい
僕たちは小さかったあの巨大な軍を撤退さ
せるということは
できたら奇跡だと笑われた戦いでしたでも
最後にはその軍も撤退しましたこれは
夢でも幻想でもなく現実に起きたことで目
に見えない力も僕らを助けてくれたから
どうか信じて
恐れないであなたの道を進んでくださいと
いう伝言でし
た命が喜ぶ仕事って何でしょう
きっと誰に反対されても体が向かおうと
するようなこと
何か説明できないような力が体の奥底から
湧いてくるような
楽しくて楽しくて仕方ないようなそんな
こと
反対に
本当の気持ちを押し殺して少しずつ自分
らしい道を諦めていった先に東ティモール
で起きたような
悲しいこともつながっていってしまう
誰かものすごい悪人がいて
戦争や自然破壊が起きているんじゃない
私たちが少しずつ
自分の夢を諦めて自分に蓋をして
大きい声に流されて
創立して無関心になっていく
それが回り回って大きな戦争や自然破壊に
までつながっていってしまう
あなたしかできないこと
あなたがやるべきこと
体は大切なシグナルを送ってそれをあなた
に教えてくれているはずです
道を歩いていて足が止まってしまったり
鳥肌が立ったり
涙が出ちゃったり
頭で考えるよりも先に現れる大事な
シグナルを体は送ってくれているはずです
そうして一歩踏み出した先では
あなたの想像を超えるとてつもない力が
発揮される
そこに出会うべき仲間がいます
自分の中から沸き起こる力を信じて
ください
それはきっと世界中で連鎖していく
そんな世界を見てみたいと思いませんか
あなたがあなたらしい道をどうか歩めます
ように
ありがとうございました
[拍手]